based on the evidence that we've
gathered at this point we've come to the
conclusion
that an individual named anthony
warner is the bomber
developing out of nashville tonight
authorities say the man responsible for
the explosion that rattled downtown
nashville on christmas morning
died in the blast authorities say
warner's remains were found near the
scene of that explosion
before it happened there was a warning
saying a potential bomb would detonate
within 15 minutes
because of that officers had time to
evacuate those nearby
i was thrown forward knocked to the
ground but i was able to catch myself i
was fine
i just felt a push basically i was
thrown into the trunk a little bit
turned around to see
just a very orange sky a lot of smoke
i literally hear a guy tell me to turn
around and go check on topping who was
by herself
down on broadway and
as i turned around for me it felt like
i only took three steps and then the
music stopped
and as i'm walking back towards topping
now
i just see orange and then i hear a loud
boom
and as i'm stumbling because it rocked
me that hard i started stumbling i just
tell myself to stay on your feet stay
alive
the explosion threw flames into the air
setting cars on fire destroying homes
and
damaging more than 40 businesses in the
city's tourist district
police say no one else is believed to
have been involved in the explosion
at this time